breaking right now at four o'clock a
teenager is the center of two homicide
investigations thanks for joining us at
4 i'm vanessa murphy and i'm christian
costas the 8 news now i-team breaking
this story this afternoon the suspect
alonso brown in custody metro just held
a press conference and that is where we
find victoria saha she was there and
she's got more information victoria
metro police just releasing new
information about an 18 year old charged
with murder who police say is now
connected to an unsolved case back in
may police say alonso brown lived
extremely close to both homicide scenes
they believe he is a suspect in last
thursday's murder where a man was shot
and killed near tropicana and boulder
highway the victim was found with
multiple gunshot wounds witnesses tell
police they saw brown running through
the area and found clothing items that
match
which matched surveillance footage of
brown police say brown was following a
man who left a convenience store police
say there was a similar homicide in may
right in that area in that incident
police say brown shot a victim at a bus
stop surveillance footage was grainy but
officers continued to canvas the area
where they came across brown officers
ran after him and arrested him on monday
but what was especially disturbing as
they reviewed some of the surveillance
footage they noticed that the
suspect seemed to stalk the victim
they appear to be a random
killing there wasn't any apparent motive
from what we could tell
our i-team has learned brown was also
connected to a hit-and-run crash last
year while being arrested police say
they found two guns on brown police also
believe that if brown would have
committed more violent crimes if he
wasn't arrested victoria saha live local
now